it's not interesting watching people
or complain or be mad like it's
not it's not fun yep but everybody's mad
and frustrated about everything all the
time so if you can sort of tap into that
like the first video I ever ever made
that was seen the iPod the iPod my
brother van and I made this in 2003 it's
three years before YouTube was a thing
and my iPad I was broke I had no
money to my name this thing was it was
399 it was a gift yeah and the battery
died a year later and I called apple and
they're like nah just buy a new one so I
called them back and I recorded the call
yeah they're like just buy a new one and
I was like yeah okay and I was like
great audio and then they had those
posters where it's like the black
silhouette or the white silhouette where
you see the coordinates like color and
we put like cigarette disclaimers on
every poster with a spray paint stencil
iPads
iPods Irreplaceable battery lasts only
18 months and we put it on a splash page
like a we made an iPod 30secret.com
because there's no YouTube and it went
so viral so quickly and by the way in
2003 viral means you copy the the URL
you put in an email you type in friends
names you click Send there's no YouTube
there is no you there's no Twitter
there's no Instagram
and like it was so blew up so quickly
that the head of the hosting company
called my cell phone and he's like I
want you to know we have not pulled your
site yet but you're a lot like monthly
allowances 10 gigabytes of bandwidth and
right now you're at like four terabytes
oh wow because so many people have gone
to the sets especially in 2003 yeah so I
posted on this I was like we need help
hosting this and I think it was like
maybe a couple universities were like
we'll put it on our University
um servers you're good and that was like
slowing them down and it just kept like
we could not find a place to sustain it
and then this is such a fun story and
then we figured out the time like now
you've got iCloud but back then you had
something that's called idisc then you
could have like an apple hosted website
to share like baby videos and stuff
there was no bandwidth limitations so
Apple hosted the video in the end there
yeah it was like 13 a month or something
oh that's fine I doubt it yeah great and
then they changed the policy they did
but if it was just a video of me
bitching I don't think anybody would
give it a spot it was funny yeah and and
the style in which you did it it carried
through like did you I'm curious your
processing creating that did you know
what you were doing with the stencil and
all the yeah I mean that video that one
in particular like much credit to my
brother van like everything I have ever
known or learned or done that's creative
is like all credit goes to my older
brother van like he taught me everything
I know I'm just a like a very mediocre
photocopy of his like truly virtuous
creative Brilliance and like that video
in particular like that video was mostly
his idea like I edited it and I put the
like Easy E Track under it and like did
all of that but like the idea of like
let's cut out a stencil like the stencil
scene those are his hands
yeah like all credit to Van Nuys that
yeah like total such a unique
way to tell a story even now and this is
is well y'all are you're 22 I don't know
how old van is but that's 20 years ago
literally it's wild and that style was
even now you're like that's a great
that's unique